what's going on with you man man trying
to be a hipster man I respect it it's a
nice like uh late life decision to Pivot
to yeah man I'm going through a
different personalities it's my history
personally so you're in hipster mode of
bizarre's career right now are we
changing them are you singing about uh
trans rights and stuff wow you're
changing it up yeah I gotta change it up
man the New Millennium man do you feel
like when you listen to your music at
times like from like back in the day and
even you know newer stuff
it's obviously
you'd be saying some wild [ __ ]
especially like vintage D12 [ __ ] because
I always think like damn like I always
like talk to artists about like just
kind of the state of how sensitive
everybody is nowadays I'm like yeah I
don't know if Marshall Mathers help you
could happen in 2022 like I don't know
if that was purple purple pills could
happen in 2022 or Devil's Night like is
that uh do you ever like listen to your
old [ __ ] and be like damn I was saying
some wild [ __ ]
yeah I'll be for getting halfway should
I be saying man what do you think is
like the craziest line you've said on a
song that you think might like if it if
it came out today would get you in some
serious [ __ ]
uh
uh I don't know maybe the uh you know my
hands are so numb
my mother sucked my dick and I didn't
come um that's one of the raunchy ones
I don't know any [ __ ] about kids
probably gonna be probably super
offensive yeah anything about it'd be
like Aries Spears
who's your experience he saw he did a
bit he did a bit about kids like 12
years ago they're trying to cancel him
now for it because it's like damn
rehashed damn him and Tiffany haddish
are in the skit in like 2012. yeah and
people are mad about it all like out of
nowhere oh wow yeah every Spirit let's
do that dude okay yeah yeah great he
does great impersonations his Jay-Z
impersonation is insane his DMX one is
dope yeah yeah they like trying to
cancel my man give me my get his ass out
of there it's crazy man it's crazy
nowadays like uh how would you say like
you know
being bizarre knowing that you're kind
of
like I feel like when people listen to
Bazaar they're expecting a certain level
of like shock value or or is it like a
little harder to deliver that how you'd
like to nowadays
uh
uh well I think I'm being a little bit
more lyrical now
um with the shock but I still stick my
little punches in there I think it's my
that's just about my my brain is wired
man right so I'm a little bit more
sneakier with the punches but they still
they're still they're still flagrant
they're still funny yeah
yeah your [ __ ] was always hilarious
right yeah I feel like you could have
did stand up yeah you know I'm but I'm
trying to scale back a little bit uh
I say one or two like I think I said
something about a little Nas X
he ain't important especially after he
didn't get that abortion
oh cause he was pregnant yeah about me
yeah
he was a pregnant male
it was a nice rollout hey it was a good
rollout hey had people talking you wrote
a bar about it worked right damn yeah so
I'm still sneaking them in yeah
I don't think people take my [ __ ]
serious man I think I think they kind of
know you're like whether people other
people can't say what I say yeah if
someone if someone else said that it'd
be a problem but I feel like people
expect that level of like comedy or like
at least like they're not gonna take it
like personal if you say it all right
but what if I'm serious well I don't
know and you could have stopped to help
me before I really
committed a serious crime
oh that would be crazy I couldn't stop
you yeah you could have talked to me
yeah this guy over here with the mullet
is that's his job I love man he's Juiced
up off bang oh man oh he won't talk
about his Red Bull let's see this guy
smoked two packs of black amount a day